2021 could be on pace to be america's
deadliest year of gun violence in the
last two decades
yesterday president biden announced a
new strategy to combat it
and includes a zero tolerance policy for
gun dealers who break federal law
deploying strike teams to cities to
crack down on illegal gun trafficking
and encouraging communities to use
federal pandemic relief funds for
policing and crime prevention
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in new york city with a look at
the rise
of violence that led to the new
initiative david good morning
good morning we wanted to know why so we
went to princeton university to speak
with a sociologist who studies crime for
a living
and he believes there are three shocks
that have contributed to the rise in
crime number one
the shutdown of core institutions during
the pandemic
second a record number of gun sales and
third protests during the pandemic in
the aftermath of those protests
you'll hear from that sociologist in a
moment but this morning we're focusing
on the specific number of murders that
are on the rise
take chicago last weekend police say
during the puerto rican day festivities
surveillance video captured giovanni
orzwaga and yasmine perez being ambushed
after a minor traffic accident
according to authorities yasmine was
pulled from the car beaten
and shot when giovanni tried to save her
he was gunned down almost
execution style both of them were killed
it's hard to believe that he's gone a
young guy is gone
just because of an accident in new york
city two children narrowly avoided being
shot as a gunman
shot at a man on a busy city street
and in austin texas this month gunfire
broke out early one morning in the
city's nightlife district
one person was killed 13 more were
injured
nearly 10 000 people have been killed
this year alone
from gun violence and it's not letting
up in a study of 24 major cities
homicides increased by 24
in the first quarter of 2021 compared to
the same time period in 2020
and by 49 from that period in 2019
so far this year homicides are up nearly
14
in new york city 22 in los angeles
and by 13 in washington d.c compared to
last year
the frustrating thing is no one has to
has
identified the the magic solution
stephen adler is the mayor of austin
texas and he is hoping to reverse the
trends
the city is on track to greatly surpass
its
own homicide record which was set just
last year
we have too many illegal weapons that
are falling into the wrong hands
we have to try to find those illegal
weapons and take them off the street
for patrick sharkey a sociologist at
princeton university
the answer goes well beyond illegal
firearms and law enforcement
in the u.s we have this knee-jerk
reaction where we think only about the
police and the prison system
as the responsibility as a sociologist
who studies gun violence in america
do you believe that abolishing the
police is a good idea
no i don't think it's a good idea we
have
300 400 million guns on the street so we
don't have another set of institutions
that can respond to gun violence like
the police can
our primary focus should be investing in
these other institutions
that can deal with addiction mental
illness provide after school programs
here's some perspective there's one
analysis that took a look at about 20
big cities around the country and found
that roughly one percent of the calls
police officers are responding on
involve calls of violence where a gun or
a knife is involved just one percent
so the sociologist you just heard from
is a proponent of let's save the police
for those calls
but let's send in better trained people
to deal with a large majority
of everything else david bagno for us in
new york
thank you